hello everyone
uh good evening uh and welcome to
uh the pi data meetup uh berlin august
uh session uh me and kasich roy will be
presenting a work on knowledge infused
uh statistical learning
for social good uh applications and uh
so uh predominantly like today's talk
would be
uh more specific to so it's more of like
developing a conceptual understanding of
how knowledge graphs of prior knowledge
can be integrated
into statistical nlp in improving its
performance
in terms of getting explanations and
actually making sense to
the subject matter experts in cases
where you are dealing with people who
are from non-profits specifically
uh like medical centers or nonprofit
organizations or like humanitarian
organizations
so this talk uh oh sorry i forgot to
uh i'll allow akashik to introduce
himself
uh he and me are we he's right now in
india and i'm in us so we all three
like i think the meetup is in germany so
we have three different time zones
working
in parallel
okay so uh this
so uh this talk uh is actually is in
consequence with a past tutorial and a
pi data talk that we
uh did give at the salamanca and the
tutorial that we did in the acm
hypertext
where we actually dealt with a more
complex applications of knowledge
infused learning in
recommender systems uh community
networks specifically focusing on hate
speech and black live matters campaign
and talking about computer vision
applications as well as information
retrieval
so uh today's uh talk would be more of
like a developing at an
abstract level of how this knowledge uh
prior knowledge can be integrated into
deep learning frameworks and what are
the different applications
where they it has seemed to be giving
good results and
you can actually see some uh outcomes
which makes uh which are based
very much relatable to what uh a domain
expert or an
as a person and who is at the end is
able to make sense out of it
so the learning from this talk is uh
would be
how the prior knowledge can be endowed
into statistical learning
uh uh then what are the different forms
of prior knowledges
uh and how they can be infused
uh into your deep learning framework uh
what are the existing methods that
people have
actually touched upon build upon on
developing on using knowledge graphs
of prior knowledge and uh we will be
actually giving as
uh so basically cautiously kosher will
be giving a page in perspective to
knowledge infusion
uh which we as we call as the bayesian
knowledge prior
so from this entire talk the major
things that you can take away are the
two things
is that explainability in ai is possible
through a knowledge graph
and how is it possible we will explain
that and in this process how to unhandle
uh knowledge based uh inductive biases
uh sorry pan i
i know that you don't like
explainability in ai as a term
but us uh we apologize it's like we
actually made this presentation without
knowing that
uh so uh in this presentation we i just
before we start up i just want to give
some brief definitions uh when we say
graph
when i will be actually trying word like
graph we are actually referring to
knowledge graphs which are
graphical structures uh comprising of
entities relationships and properties
uh represent when you say representation
we are actually referring to embeddings
which are varied uh damage of dimensions
which are basically a vector or
horizontal vector
um which have like 300 dimensions 200
dimensions or 100 dime which is all in
real numbers
when we say context it is basically we
are talking about the text outside the
training data
but is relevant to the training data uh
when we say abstraction it is basically
identifying the entity types
uh for example if i say uh uh what you
call like
we can say like germany germany is part
of the european uh commission
so that your european commission can be
the entire type of germany
uh so that's an array type we can look
at the parent of a node
and sisters of a node so these are need
to be identified because you want to
resolve the ambiguity in the content
the two different things actually
talking about the same thing but they
are
expressed in a different way so
the outline of our exposition for
today's would be uh talking about more
of like statistical
learning pipeline knowledge
representations how we can use
reinforcement with user in the loop
uh how we can fuse knowledge the patient
perspective
uh there are other different ways we can
evaluate these methods
uh where are we after this uh
development of knowledge infused
learning paradigm
and what are the resources that we have
actually used tested and
utilized in our projects
uh so uh why do we actually read and
require knowledge
uh in in statistical learning uh let's
start with a simple example
uh where we we talk about us very
statistical learning framework which
involves data acquisition systems you
have millions of records
you pass it through a natural language
processing pipeline
takes pc or any other models or you have
language models of parsers
famous screen you can be taking off like
let's say you can use bert
as one of the state of the art you
extract entities relationships
events and contextual features also to
gather and you pass it through a deep
learning paradigm
and the deep learning model does the
prediction for you
the which is an outcome which is
basically the weighted features and
performance scores
now in this process uh you actually
this process raises some open questions
like does the training data that you on
which you build your model
provided a good domain coverage does the
model
uh does the labels that you are actually
predicting have adequate semantics how
do you interpret the results
so that the system can be adopted in
practice and
did the model learn features relevant to
the subject matter expert
which is pretty much important when you
are actually dealing with the
non-profits
so uh we actually uh let's just
walk through a simple example um let's
take the method one which is the
traditional deep learning uh statistical
learning pipeline
where you have a tweet uh let's say the
this tweet talks about flu pneumonia and
kobe 19
and some other factors like kill six
times more people
and you pass it through a natural
language pipeline you extract
it extracts you all the different
entities possible in the tweet
and the underlying ones are the more if
you're using self-attention or an
attention model
they will actually highlight to some of
the words which are more important
because
they are more predominantly used in
context to in context of kobe 19 as
other words compared to other words like
flu and pneumonia you generate
representations and
do the predictions now in this process
you are not
actually uh putting the thrust on what
what are the specific words maybe fluent
pneumonia is more important
than kill or six times or more people so
rather than
like uh wasting time on all of these
different entities
a different approach can be taken into
into account
where you actually pass this tweet and
you actually pass this to it in
through a knowledge graph where you
actually construct a small graph
where you say the flu pneumonia and kobe
19 are actually have a property known as
affected population because they are all
some diseases and they are all instances
of communicable diseases so you will
replace this in digestion
big tweet into just two concepts which
is affected population and communicable
diseases
and you generate a representation along
this rather than generating a
representation for a tweet
and with this results you actually try
to build you're able to
develop a more interpretable outcomes
and right you are actually getting a
more
information which is uh you can say it's
implicit in your corpus
but it is not actually allowed it's not
visible to the human
uh human eye so this actually processes
what we call it
as an abstraction and this a process
actually somehow addresses the two open
questions that we actually raised in the
previous slide
which is do the labels represent
adequate semantics so now we have a
labels which
have some semantics in it and these
results are interpretable because if
the model is being affected population
communicable diseases
then you can know that why these two
entities were actually
uh more important than the other ones
because these are the terms which are
which are you can actually traverse back
through this
in this graph so in order to do this
process what we did was we actually
leveraged wiki data
uh which is basically a knowledge graph
we can use and you can query it with
your keywords
just like you do it in a relational
databases
moving further uh this actually raises
some interesting questions in terms of
statistical learning
and let's take an example of graph
convolutional neural network
you know that we this is one of the most
powerful state-of-the-art neural network
and this neural network model does not
models relationships because it all
depends on the agency metrics
so the question comes in how you can
actually bring the relations into the
entities because
in the previous slide we actually talked
about the relationships are important
for interpretability so in this process
what we try to do is we you already have
let's say example of kobe 19 tweets
we you pass you pass through an entity
uh through an entity embedding
based model like gcn the graph
convolutional network
and you ask the question like is similar
this is a similarity task which is a
very famous
predominant task in nlp the shelter in
place causes anxiety or sheltering place
prevents anxiety the answer is yes
because
prevents is not documented or recorded
in the embedding
stage whereas when you have a graph you
know that the triples that there is a
there's a triple talking about shelter
in place causes anxiety
you pick that triple you do a factor uh
factorization model over it
over the graph you generate
representation of these triples
and you concatenate to the empire entity
embeddings
so you and with this approach you are
actually forcefully putting
uh uh inform additional information to
your gcn model so that it can attend to
causal relationships and if the so if
then it will not able to find prevents
as such as a relationship
so the difference becomes very large as
a result is similar becomes false
and the answer turns out to be no
now moving further uh we we actually try
to address
now uh the two questions whereas the
does the training data that we are
talking about
has a good domain coverage so when you
say good domain coverage
means that the prior knowledge required
for constructing the data
is not considered while training so you
get your annotated data let's say
imagenet
you talk about cfr you take our mnist
you talk about
other data sets and kaggle there are
annotated data sets have some prior
indication that the person who annotated
that has
in his mind but it is not documented in
the data set as a result
the decision boundary that you create is
approximated and not generalized
so another another question that here
that we have is
do the labels represent adequate
semantics so now how do we actually try
to make an approach to it
is consider an example through on
another twitter
tweet uh which you have which you has
been labeled as informative
now the label informative does not tell
me which part of this tweet
is uh responsible for the that that was
made
considered as important by the data to
label as informative
so what we did was we actually moved to
a different perspective where we
passes to it through a graph we say
which part of the entities or nodes of
that graph
are actually these terms in the tweet
map too
so as a result you can generate a new
set of labels and if these labels
are informative you can say create a
rules
of say let's say location and flood and
death tool are important
for a stakeholder you can actually
consider those labels to be important
and if these labels have some
probabilities that have been generated
because they have been able to map that
so that because you are able to map the
tweets to these labels
uh you are able to get a better
understanding of why this tweet was
labeled as informative
so this becomes more like a semantic and
interpretable and traceable as well
because you can trace it to the graph
so another car problem that arised in
the context of kobe 19
context was the basically the self
labeling of covet conversations
because there is a humongous amount of
conversations that are going online
and on reddit and other platforms on
news articles
on how the kobe 19 conversations can be
labeled
so in this labeling process the labeling
is important because you want more and
more information
gathered from online media which you can
actually take you can utilize
for public health decision making so in
this process
uh we took a a stab at it in a different
uh in a in a way that
what we did was we actually took the
reddit conversations we did a deep
clustering
uh neural parsing which is a very famous
passing mechanism
uh what we did was we able to do a
generate some clusters
and each cluster is represented by some
latent topics these topics are the
topics that people are actually
discussing
now having these topics can i label this
cluster is it possible to label it
so you know in a statistical manner
one would simply generate embeddings of
each and every of these topics and
concatenate
do a dimensional reduction find a
similar uh topic
that is very similar to this reduced
representation give the labels
that is also true but that results in a
another computational aspect
of it so what we did was we just pass it
through a graph
let's say we pass it through a medical
graph
and we found that these terms are
actually mapped to an anxiety so we what
we did was we actually found distance
there's a mapping between these terms
we actually and these terms are mapped
to a very uh like a parent node
which is in this case it's an anxiety
we're able to label that cluster as
anxiety
so you actually reduce your
computational aspect by leveraging a
prior knowledge
so now we have talked about the utility
of prior knowledge like what exactly it
is
it's basically a graph it's basically
some information uh but
what i let's just have a concrete
definition of and the various forms of
prior knowledge
so prior knowledge what we consider in
throughout our presentation is that it
is information external to the data set
but used implicitly while constructing
the data set
and it needs to be machine readable uh
like for example
you can talk about online articles you
have you you all be aware of that
there are millions of scientific
articles on kobe 19 that have been made
public
and which you can use use to understand
unstructured content
so there are actual forms of it you have
ebooks epubs and permanent articles
which are scientific places and you have
description of entities you can gather
from
even the the if you publish your
research paper right
every research paper in acm has a ccs
you can use ccs
as a way to make an understanding of
your article so those become
your entities and the keywords that you
provide in your research article those
are also a set of entities
something very similar in is in the
medical literature they call as a
medical subject headings
or mesh now in this
uh uh another set of the data is
basically the images
which is uh radio pd and image net they
are both are
in their own domain one of the largest
resources of information which you know
so radio
radio media is used to understand the
radiology report and image
and capture engineering captions for the
radiology
images and image net you can use for
the recent work in cvpr we saw that it
used it was used to
basically develop scene understanding in
those cases where
you do not have sufficient data so it's
more like a zero shot
transfer learning uh paradigm so in the
graph based
uh you have broad based which is frame
net frame net
can be used to understand the events it
has recently been integrated into an ltk
uh atomic is basically a a knowledge
graph which is common sense reasoning
which says like let's say if x
interjects y
then not of x not interjects y
not of x not interjects not of y and x
interjects
not of y so you can create all different
forms
of this this logical forms using atomic
and some very similar likewise you have
concept net for multilinguality
and not always you you you require a
broad based knowledge source
even a domain specific knowledge source
can be uh
useful for example uh medical terms uh
you have snomed cd and icd-10 in europe
we can use icd-9 as well they are all
hierarchical structures and likewise we
have drug abuse ontology and opioid drug
knowledge graph which has been used to
understand the drug communications or
drug related communications on
on social media okay i just got a
question
uh about how do you figure out the
knowledge classes are they handcrafted
by expert or infer by some algorithm
okay
so uh the there how do we
so first of all uh the knowledge graphs
are actually constructed
uh by default by on uh through an
algorithm so what do we want
essentially you do is uh you actually
have a large resource let's say you have
a scientific article or you have let's
say i take any paper in acm
and i passed i passed this an acm paper
through a knowledge
through a natural language processing
pipeline where we actually identify
entities and relationships from those
terms so you can just create entity and
you can say entities
relationships can be anything that is
describing two terms
and uh are and the entities you can be
like the terms as well or you can have
the events as well
so you can have this triples and when
you once you have these triples what uh
in the resource or
as an index then you can actually run a
traversal algorithm to find the links
between these entities and you construct
a knowledge graph
and that's how you actually create a
knowledge graph computationally another
way
is what i was about to show in the next
slide is this is a graph
which is created by human so this is a
sars graph
uh basically i would say it's more
specific as a causality network
that people have created uh for that a
person like i think that this paper this
our
image is taken from helping 2006 which
is one of the most
famous and uh paper on disaster
management and network
where the person has actually created
this graph by hand
and essentially what you are trying to
do is you want to take this graph
and you want to create your own graph
computationally just
keep in mind that whatever entities you
are finding in that graph
in that computationally are actually
similar to the ones that have been
mentioned with this thing
so you can leverage this as a as a as a
ground truth resource to
construct your own graph uh is it clear
or did i make something
please sophie ask another question if
it's not clear
otherwise which was okay
is it clear
yes okay
uh okay so uh this is basically an
example of
a knowledge which actually created by a
human
and what we did was in this we just
leveraged this graph
and we constructed a sub graph of this
so the way we created the subgraph of
this
information is was through manual uh
uh involvement where we say that we have
the sars
and we know that the people are more
interested in some events let's say
travel bans hospitalizations quarantine
and we see how these terms are more
important so we
we have this graph for now this in this
graph we actually ignore the
relationships
we are not talking about we assume that
these are all causal relations because
it was derived from a graph which is
causality network
and what we essentially did was we use
these this graph
as as as a entities that should guide
our natural language processing pipeline
so if i'm using a self-attention
mechanism i would actually try to uh
emphasize on
on on specifics that the
the attention mechanism should be
actually focusing on these terms
so what when we are looking at the
natural language processing engine
we wanted to we wanted it to actually
focus on terms which are
are which are being used in social media
adjacent on
in the nearby context to the terms we
mentioned in this graph
so if say let's say parents protest so
there are like then
the president protests and schools
closer has to be like there needs to be
in the closed vicinity of this content
or if there are two tweets one where one
is talking about parents protest another
two is talking about schools closed
we can still say that they are actually
related to each other because parent con
appearance part protest is more relevant
or more associated to schools closed
uh there are certain emerging events
that might occur during any pandemic or
epidemic or any
crisis uh so with that for that we
actually
ignore some of the emerging events we
only consider those events which people
have actually highlighted in the
previous epidemic
and we want to govern we want to
leverage that uh
understanding to actually guide the kobe
19 scenario
so we actually identified entities or
relationships as well as the events
which are
uh described in association with these
are
are basically described in the context
window of these terms
and what we did was once we identify
those terms you took any
general purpose embedding model and you
cluster those entities
and when you cluster them uh you are
able to see that you are able you can
you're able to generate clusters which
are more uh
worse which describe more worse
condition because there are there is one
route
in this graph which is more worse than
the other one for example travel bans
and economic and unemployment
quarantine so basically you are saying
that what we have showed you is
a as an example subgraph but definitely
you can have multiple we have
created multiple subgraphs of this kind
which represents different
uh conditions as well so you have
cluster which is
describing more worsen conditions and
then you have a cluster which is
described more like good conditions
where people are more talking about
staying
home and quality so you can actually
describe you can actually have discrete
clusters
which you will look at it you can
actually make sense of it because the
value of making sense you are actually
leveraging this graph as
as a background information
now in this uh slide we i talked about
a graph which is created by humans let's
talk about a graph which is created by
uh through computational purpose so uh
the one which is
predominantly the last scale graph which
actually i i
used in my uh research specific to
social good application is available net
so the bevel net is pretty accessible
through python api
uh you can actually get a key and access
it and if you pass
what essentially does is that if you
pass a tweet let's say waterborne
disease on
rice in texas as hurricane harvey water
recedes
what it does is that it identifies the
name entities and concepts
in this tweet so and it simultaneously
gives you additional informations
now there's two benefit of people using
bible net that i was able to find and
was useful to me
was the beyblade description and
babelnet hypernames
so if i have a tweet in hurricane harvey
and i have a tweet in earthquake
can i find an association of between
events that happen in two different
geological phenomena
that is possible because babelnet
identifies these two as geological
phenomena
so you can find some association between
these tweets since these two events are
actually related
through a parent uh note known as
geological phenomena
likewise you can actually use this uh
descriptions that are being provided
to better understand your tweets right
and also you can simultaneously create a
parallel
corpus of so you pass all your tweets
through bible net it will give you all
the descriptions
and then you can actually do some kind
of a curation uh which is kind of a
manual
uh involvement uh but essentially you
can create a parallel corpus and you can
actually train your own domain specific
embedding model
which is pretty interesting specifically
when you want a very
targeted model only for a very targeted
problem
so uh uh similarly we actually
utilized uh so there's another problem
statement for
uh where we actually used uh knowledge
graph was to understand the kobe 19
related entities
in the spa in the sparse news article so
you have sparse news articles
uh basically like not all articles will
be very enriched because right now as
you know
that in kobe 19 uh most people are in
the race of
putting things out on the web so not all
articles are very rich in the
information they are just part of it
and you want to use you want to extract
entities from these past articles
so what we did was we took this past
articles and we pass it through through
different mechanisms one was
self-attention mechanism and other was
dbpedia which is a graph and we found
that there are these two sources are
actually finding
nearly the same information so the only
thing is that
uh neural passing was able to identify
more information
uh which is not that much related to
uh influenza but more on like a general
purpose not information whereas the ue
beta was able to find information more
like cdc
and information influencer like diseases
but interestingly none of those
resources actually identify that
influenza is of
what other what type of influence i was
describing that news article
so that's why we use a snomed on graph
where we pass this thing and we are able
to identify that the influence of
of one typo is one of the another
entities so you are actually doing no
computation party just
passing your content through a series of
knowledge graphs a series of resources
where you are able to tag more entities
in your informations
before you actually move on to use them
in your search process
for identifying more tweets relevant to
uh kobe 19.
so in this for this building this it was
pretty easy and we actually use some of
the shelf
public apis uh like rdflip snowstorm
first nomad ct
uh berkeley and europasser and gdelt
knowledge source which actually are very
large
not resource for the news articles
likewise uh there there was one another
interesting application that we found in
kobe 19 where the knowledge graph was
of use was the identifying the
depressive and what actually identifying
the negative media exposure
because uh the media was making news and
there is a negative media exposure
related to kobe 19 which has affected
the health of a lot of people
and it is imp impractical to annotate
all the millions of
news articles that was one of the
challenge that we had another one is
how do we identify depressive drug abuse
and informative tweets
when we say informative means
informative for the people
and not for the public health expert we
want the information to be helpful for
the
public and public do not want to forget
information which is more depressive and
drug abuse related
so what we did was we just pre uh used
uh an a a graph this graph has been
recorded in neo4j we actually
took the concepts of this graph and
there's a vocabulary.txt file invert
you pass this graph you pass this
concept or you augment this concept to
the vocabulary.txt
and you retrofit the google birth model
using a k nearest neighbor algorithm
where
kenya's nearest neighbor algorithm is a
clustering approach
where what you are trying to say is that
you are used want
you already know your centroids and you
want to
put position all the words near to the
centroids so that's why you actually
create a new set of graph where
centroids are nothing but the concepts
in this centrology and all the words
are nearby and that's what you use to
actually create a drug abuse
but and then you do a bird classifier
where you get information from two
different communities
interestingly we what we did was we just
used the reddit communities as such
so the drug abuse communities reddit
were level one and the other any other
community which is not in drug abuse
related
are label zero and we just train a bird
classifier
on this related resource the weighted
concepts that we got
we use that to actually identify their
their occurrences in the news articles
to find the uh exposure of uh
information the media exposure on the on
different parts different states are in
the u.s
and we really we did a statistical
hypothesis testing
between what the ground truth ranking
says and what is the ranking that we
have provided
and it was statistical significant at i
think 0.1
uh still a lot of work needs to be done
in this uh
but it was fairly understandable of why
these
places have high media exposure
uh this concludes my part of the
talk where i explore explored uh the
various statistical learning methods
how what are the what is the prior
knowledge how the prior knowledge can be
integrated into a deep learning paradigm
and also we given through some series of
examples of
understanding uh application like new
negative media exposures
identifying causal topics in twitter
during in during the kobe 19
conversations
and we are talking about how we can
actually extract uh useful entities even
from the sparse
news articles or sparse resources uh i
move
uh i just hand over to koshek who will
be talking about the base diffused
knowledge
and the bayesian perspective to
knowledge infusion
thank you minus um so first thing that
i would like to talk about with respect
to the applications that we have
discussed so far you will notice that
they're
social good applications like kobit so
for the importance of evaluation in
these models so that people can use them
we would like a human to be involved
while both learning and evaluating the
model and
the human provides reinforcement in
various ways to aid the
statistical learning pipeline for
example here you can see that
the patterns that the deep learning
pattern recognition module learns
they the they can be evaluated by the
human because the human is
uh considered to be an expert in the
domain that it's being used in
and uh the human can also um
provide additional knowledge that might
be required to
reconcile some of the examples that
external publicly available knowledge
couldn't do and
similarly our knowledge system can
in turn query the human if
it requires a particular example space
to contain a rule that it can't find in
its database
um then next i'd like to
discuss how to fuse the types of
knowledge that manus has talked about
into the statistical learning pipeline
so we at the ai institute have uh
explored two ways um
the two flavors that we have tried are
shallow infusion of knowledge and
semi-deep infusion shallow infusion like
it sounds
happens at a shallow level so that means
at the input level
and so you have inputs for your data
data representation the inputs for your
knowledge
uh knowledge representations and we
would like to combine them into a
multiplex representation
a simple way to do that might just be
concatenation the two vectors place them
side by side
another way that you could do it is run
a dimensionality reduction technique on
the representations
and across those most important
dimensions
you would then concatenate them so that
your downstream nlp test can just use
the
important most most significant
dimensions among
all of them a third way would be to have
it
have the multiplexing process itself be
a learning problem so
a non-linear combination of the two
types of input that can be learned
but i in all these three ways the
shallow infusion method
uh tries to incorporate our knowledge uh
just at the input level and then it is
passed on to the rest of the nlp
pipeline
in the semi-deep method we also
use the knowledge to modify the
parameters of the model
any prediction function it relies not
only on the data but also on the
parameters of the model and typically
the way that it functions is that
there are certain predictions associated
with your examples and
uh it tries to learn the best fit
parameter that
mimics those predictions the best and
that's
called maximum likelihood estimation but
in
so echobate 19 for instance uh maybe we
can't trust it
because it's an ongoing pandemic and so
there may be three days in a row where
the induction rate is 50
and if we try to go with a maximum
likelihood estimate
we'll falsely conclude that um it's much
more dangerous than it seems
um so we would like to instead temper
that sort of an estimate with
regularization from a prior knowledge
base like um
we know that wikipedia a wiki data item
on covet 19 would show that it's a
subclass of a car another so
the infection rate associated with the
coronal virus could be
used as a more sensible initial estimate
and
that could be um move towards the data
likelihood slowly
and so that that way some edp infusion
is
um more useful in
social good applications and
traditionally this can happen i mean
theoretically that this can happen in
any machine learning algorithm but we
have done it only for deep learning
methods
specifically we've done it in neural
attention models
so the popular
one right now is the self-attention
model i'm sure
you are you all are aware of it or i
hope
burt is a transformer architecture that
uses the cell potential model
recently gpt3 is also based on the
transformer architecture that uses the
cell potential model
so what the idea behind an attention
model is that
you have a certain input and in a
prediction task
the model learns to pay attention to
different parts of the input
as you can see here the old school of
thought and attention models before
self-attention came out was
um as it's shown here the for
predicting uh that you need to provide
stimulus to the economy at this point
the neural network learned to pay
attention to the phrases lose their jobs
unable to pay rent and meet basic
expenditures
from that input sentence but when
self-attention models came out
um it started mimicking a more graphical
structure it started learning implicitly
a more graphical structure for example
the different tokens in the sentence
learned to attend to
other tokens in a sentence to varying
degrees and that creates a graph
and then you can create a representation
for the different tokens much like you
would in a
graph convolutional neural network by
aggregating representations from its
neighbors
and then you use those constructed
representations
in a feed forward layer to predict the
outcome
some others have also tried a knowledge
infusion
and leslie valiant he's from harvard he
uh came up with this method in 2006 so
uh he his method um
poses knowledge as different rules about
the world
with each rule having its own
uncertainty measure
now these rules are not independent
depending on how they interact with each
other
uh the infusion technique will have to
define semantics to
calculate the probability the
uncertainty measures for those joint
configurations
uh variant called these pieces of
knowledge teaching material
and the main argument
the the main pro of this method as they
argue is that
it helps with robustness in the face of
learning from noisy real world data
and real world data is very noisy
especially during an ongoing pandemic
and the theoretical contribution here
is that they provide backbones to say
when is it worth it to construct
external knowledge to infuse in your
model
because they argue that if it's
too time consuming or computationally
intractable then
we should just not do it um
yeah the another way
a more neurosymbolic way to
infuse knowledge that has been tried
recently is uh
knowledge infusion in birth but again i
talked about already is a transformer
model so it uses a self-attention
framework
so you can think of this as a shallow
infusion model um
it uses the data from online web sources
and knowledge and constructs a
representation and concatenates the two
um and that's passed through vanilla
bird and
here you can see an example of such
knowledge that if a city if the number
of cases in a city for kobe 19 is
greater than two percent of the
population
then um
kovid 19 and that city are probably
going to be contextually relevant in
the articles that follow and it is
augmented with an uncertainty scope
this way of knowledge infusion was
carried out at startling lab at ut
dallas and
it's not neurosymbolic instead
it's more purely symbolic so in
inductive logic programming which tries
to learn rules from data
they use an algorithm called gradient
boosting to learn the rules from data
and it the additional advantage is that
it also
simultaneously learns the uncertainty
values and they have figured out a way
to incorporate expert advice knowledge
into this model during the learning
process
and they have adapted this algorithm to
a regression setting
uh to cause sensitivity constraint
settings for example in medical domain
this will this is really important
if you'd much rather test someone as a
false positive then not test them when
they actually have
an illness so you'd like to provide that
type of information to
your learning algorithm so and a common
theme in the
the ones that i've discussed so far is
that
while predicting something they give you
the best prediction
right but in social good applications
and especially uncertain ones like over
90
um you don't know what the best outcome
is
um you and it's likely that all the
outcomes that your model predicts
are sort of have the same or
similar uncertainty measures and it's
not very peaky that distribution over
the outcomes and so maybe you would like
the entire distribution and construct
your own statistics on it to make
predictions and maybe
construct other informative things like
uh
bounds on how correct is your answer so
with that
we see the need for a bayesian approach
that can output such a distribution
so i'll talk about how bayesian learning
can be used in
semi-deep infusion and the concept of
priors and posteriors
so here you can see in this architecture
diagram that
a knowledge prior looks like a set of
rules you can think of it as or a
formula 5
1 that applies to an example x and if
that
formula applies now that formula could
be a logical rule it could be a path in
a knowledge graph it could simply be
a set of features that are satisfied
about an example
and when that happens you basically
encode as prior knowledge the
probability of
a particular parameter value and because
your prediction depends on this
parameter value
this essentially defines what are what
should be your initial set of
sensible predictions then as you see
more data
x the update rule the bayesian update
rule
uh shows us the probability of the
parameters post seeing some data
and that's called the posterior
probability
the formulas are on the example still
apply so phi 1 of x and pi 2 of x still
apply
and they actually help with providing
explanations on the posterior
as well as the prime then finally with
those
parameters you can use it in any
downstream task here are some
examples of structured prayers um so
behavioral patterns when dealing with
kobe some leaders
are more adventurous than others and so
you can put that in a rule by saying
that
if some leader of a country is is
risk-averse
meaning they're not that adventurous uh
that implies that
any parameter theta that results in the
prediction
f of an example comma theta being high
risk
should be of low probability right
that's what the first rule says
uh a second example would be cause
sensitivity biases
so in general in a say a country like
denmark
there could be a general rule saying
that if a person belongs to community c
in denmark then any parameter that
results in the
function predicting that that person
should wear a mask
should be of high probability uh but
then
you might look at some social media
conversation and
uh realize that uh some people in a
community
um are titling it right like family
or friends and so you could put that
type of information in your model as you
can see in the rule before that
if a person is part of a community and
the community is trusted
then you instead of you deviate from the
general knowledge to making the
probability of that type of parameter
lower than
high and the third type
is simple sanity checks like i already
mentioned
instead of assuming your data estimate
which can
show arbitrarily uh
arbitrary things based on what happened
like 50 infection rate um you want to
tell your model that that's probably
not sensible and it's likely to be
a poisson distributed around the count
of
three which which says something like
three and a hundred people
uh are likely to get this type of virus
here is another useful way to
incorporate a structured prayer but we
um first
yeah um uh
yeah so how to incorporate fairness um
so we
if uh we are trying to predict if two
countries how that would fare against
kobe 19 and
we'd like to see if development index is
a good factor to consider
now a naive model might just think that
developed countries would fare
better than developing countries and
that's not a fair comparison so we can
include that in the model by tempering
the effect of the developed factor
by that is actually we would do that by
sampling it from a
sampling process like a variational
autoencoder and setting it to mostly
zeros
all over and that is that way it doesn't
affect anything upstream
um but just doing that for everything is
not
uh is not maybe can have other
consequences so
um so um
we would like to impose structure to say
that
yeah excuse me to interrupt you um so
it's maybe more than half an hour now
could you think you could
wrap it up in around five minutes so
that we have some time
for interaction afterwards
yeah i can have it up in time in next in
the next few minutes
okay um
yeah so here's an example of a
structured prior that
incorporates awareness constraint like
if we're comparing two countries one of
them is in the european union one
of them is a sac country then you'd like
the development factor not to be
considered so much
and that's what this rule is saying
so now we're going to talk about how to
evaluate knowledge and choose models
and before we do any fancy evaluation
we'll do a bunch of preliminary checks
like
concepts that are present in your
knowledge graph and training data
we just like to see if there are
representations in a representation
space are close to each other
we'd like that to happen first
secondly we we want there to be
statistically significant improvement
when
knowledge infusion is involved third is
that
we expect the word clouds that mana
showed you earlier an example of
to be more sensible when we use
knowledge guided feature representations
and we can see that by eyeballing it and
when we use dimensionality reduction
techniques
across the significant dimensions we
expect the cluster quality to be much
higher than if we didn't use knowledge
in fusion
and finally because we have several
humans in the loop
for ethical concerns and it's good sense
we'd like all of them to agree on the
prediction outputs
it should agree with their mental models
they have to trust the outcomes and of
course it needs to be accurate
an example of a evaluation with an
explanation
would be so where there is prior
information in the form of structure
like this
and you would think that theta
development should be zeroed out when
you're comparing eu and sarc countries
but somehow the model learned that
let's not do that after its learning
process it figured out that theta should
not be zeroed out so this could serve as
an explanation to
the human in the loop to say that okay
these are the type of examples where
your advice did not really make sense
or the model doesn't think you're right
where
there is no explanation in your prior
structure then you have to rely on the
attention weights of the attention model
like i showed earlier
so where are we um in ai methods for
these type of applications
initially there were expert systems and
then when there were
was big data they started using
supervised learning signals into
learning these policies uh predictions
and then the they realize that that's an
expensive process to collect labels and
labels are often noisy so
they made up for the noise by
referencing external knowledge sources
and that moved on to distant supervision
of the type that manus talked about a
little bit earlier that
you have uh two drugs and you know the
relationships between them
by referring to the drug ontology drug
abuse ontology and
that can serve as labels you don't
actually need any data labels you can
self-label your data set
finally we are knowledge infused
learning methods we just
it doesn't stick to just using knowledge
to add label semantics but does more
than that by modifying parameters
giving you bayesian posteriors etc
this is code for all the methods that
i've discussed and their papers
and i think it's all open source and on
github
so thank you we'll take questions and
our other projects are at wiki.aisc.edu
thank you great
okay do we have any question
the
the chat one is the hardest one
i i would like have one um
so where
where do you see this field going in the
next year
so where do you think will be the next
in which direction
should that go especially the next
breakthrough
so in this work there is actually a
third type of knowledge infusion that
we have been looking into that
would be my answer to where it's going
so it's called deep infusion
at every layer of the neural network it
represents different abstractions
right hierarchical abstraction and we
would like to identify those
abstractions and
provide different types of knowledge at
each layer of abstraction
and have it be traceable to the type of
knowledge that we are providing in terms
of explainability and interpretability
we are working on those type of models i
think that's where the future is
heading to that uh so this the first
paper if you if you if you get a chance
to look at it
that's a bart which is basically the
bayesian perspective to knowledge
infusion uh
it's a basically it talks about how uh
contrastive divergence and
uh like some of the functions that uh uh
koshi told about talked about
uh if i can let me show you really quick
uh
this formulation that you see learning
an inference is what they have used to
identify to actually deduce analogy
between the data sets
so once you are able to find analogical
relationships between two domains you
are able to if
and you have a label data set on one
domain you can actually leverage the
analogy to actually label another data
set
so you do not need a lot of data sets to
uh
to refer for every other task if the two
tasks have some logical relationships
you can leverage
one data sets uh a labeled data set in
one domain to label another domain
and that's exactly what this paper uh
uh talks about uh the first one which
actually we used
to explain the semi-deep infusion task
and
analogy is one such uh application
domain where we
seek that uh use of knowledge is pretty
nice and in overall if you summarize
basically the prior knowledge is used to
reduce
the amount of training datasets and uh
there is a
startup which actually came up from
google or from stanford which
uses weekly supervised methods uh not
exactly knowledge graphs but
a weekly supervised method in terms of
other labeled data sets to label
unlabeled data sets
so it's uh the the approach that they
call is called snorkel
uh which uses this uh weekly supervised
methods to
through a matrix i think we didn't go
into that much
mathematics but yeah so assume this
thing that you have an encoder and
decoder
and what you want to do is you want to
encode your
uh label data set and your decoder would
be your label data set
you want your labels to be generated for
your unlabeled data set using the labels
for your label data sets so that's the
way that they define as an encoding and
decoding optim
uh approach where and at the end you
have a matrix where you have
all the uh let's say the rows would be
your unlabeled
lib uh values and your unlabeled data
samples and
whatever you have in the column side
would be the labels for those
and uh for those label data sets so you
get kind of kind of a matrix
and the values would be the
probabilities of how much this label
aligns to that particular data sample
okay thank you very much that's
good good answer thank you um
so we don't have
any further questions so thank you very
much again for the talk
uh was really interesting um i will